think media happy new year from myself
and sean bradley yep that's me we're
super excited hope you're doing well we
want to invite you to an upcoming
five-day free youtube challenge i've got
some good news for you in this video
about the creator economy stick around
i'll tell you all the details plus i got
some news for you and bro i'm making a
video you got to just press record let
me ask you a question are you trying to
get your first 1000 subscribers on
youtube this year maybe you haven't even
started your channel yet or you feel
stuck or plateaued or like your channel
isn't growing if that's the case one i
don't blame you because youtube
competition is higher than ever before
and it's hard to figure out what's
working on youtube right now what videos
to post that's what this youtube
challenge is all about to register you
can just go to
tube1kchallenge.com and you'll see all
the information there and really the
difference between this challenge and
the other videos here on think media is
we go through like one topic at a time
one quick video upload this is an
immersive five day challenge that
honestly isn't for everybody like we're
gonna ask you to do work i'm tired of
this grandpa that's too mad we're gonna
ask you to be challenged it should be
challenging because of what i'm going to
be able to get you to do to really get
some momentum and this is for you if you
want to stop dabbling and really start
dominating on youtube this year and in a
world of what seems to be endless bad
news i wanted to share some good news
for creators and you've probably seen
the signal fire report that revealed
that being a content creator is the
fastest growing type of small business
better than starting a subway franchise
is being a content creator it's more
practical and another article came out
revealing that this industry
is evaluated at over a hundred billion
dollars so slice that up across
countries across creators across youtube
entrepreneurs small business owners on
youtube across everybody involved in the
creator economy and the truth is there's
just massive growth projected ahead for
this industry so there's really never
been a better time to have the right
strategies the right tips so if you want
some help from myself and the think
media team for free get registered for
the challenge tube1kchallenge.com link
in the description down below if by
chance you're watching this video and
you're like who even are you and why
should i listen to you when it comes to
youtube i'm the founder of this channel
think media today we have multiple
content creators who will be involved in
this challenge but it just started with
me small town kid college dropout shot a
video in my bedroom all right so uh this
is i guess the first sean thanks vlog
and now years later i've gotten a few
silver play buttons a gold play button
for this channel i wrote a book with my
friend benji called youtube secrets
which is the number one best-selling
youtube strategy book in the world i
think we're at like 80 000 copies now
i'm the creator and founder of video
ranking academy which now has thousands
of students and we have crazy success
stories i mean that's what i'm most
proud of is just really helping people
get legit results starting at zero
getting silver play buttons reaching
their goals getting leads in their
businesses so it's been a crazy journey
and if you want essentially
five immersive days of what we typically
just teach in our paid courses for free
then uh this challenge is for you so i
hope you could join myself and the think
media team
get registered
crush 2022
kick the tires light the fires rise and
grind it's time to grind
no idea what i'm saying let's just hang
out on the challenge all right peace
[Music]
down
[Music]